the White House says it would welcome
Senate testimony from Cavanaugh's other
accuser her name is Deborah Ramirez she
accuses Kavanaugh of sexual misconduct
during a drunken college party in the
1980s a claim that he denies the GOP
asked for written details from Ramirez
about any witnesses or evidence before
they speak on the phone saying it needs
that information to determine how to
proceed ramirez's lawyer john Clun says
he wants to talk before handing anything
over we spoke to him a short time ago
from Missoula Montana
John Clun good morning mr. Clun has you
or have you or your client heard from
the Senate Republicans on the Senate
Judiciary Committee you know we've had a
number of emails with the Republicans
from the Senate Judiciary Committee but
they've been refusing to speak with us
by phone we had a call set up last night
and we called in for the call and the
only people who were there was the
minority party did they say why they
didn't want to talk to you on the phone
they they say they want conditions in
place before they'll talk with us on the
phone they want us to send them all the
information that we have for their
consideration before they'll talk to us
for whatever reasons and does your
client want to testify you know she
would she would be willing to testify
but she wants to you know she wants us
to be able to have this conversation
about what this is going to look like
what the process is going to be and if
there's going to be an FBI investigation
into what happened in her case well it
seems very clear that there's not going
to be an FBI investigation is there any
chance that that she would be willing to
testify before the vote that's good that
it's now scheduled for Friday morning
yeah I'm you know first of all I don't
know what they've said to date it makes
it clear that they don't want an FBI
investigation but keep in mind that this
is the process for the background check
on any nominees for the US Supreme Court
she's admitted John to gaps in her
memory she's also reportedly said at one
point she can't exactly be sure that it
was Brett Kavanaugh who exposed himself
does that hurt her credibility no I
think that helps her credibility
I mean if somebody's going to make
something up they're not gonna put gaps
in their memory right I mean she's was
very very conscientious about only
putting forth the information
that she was comfortable with and
acknowledging the things that were the
gaps in her memories so that you know
for him as a former prosecutor I can
tell you that only helps her credibility
because somebody's not going to falsify
a report that has that kind of gap like
that all right John Clun thanks so much
for being with us thank you CBS News
will bring you live gavel-to-gavel
coverage of the Senate Judiciary
Committee hearings beginning tomorrow at
10:00 a.m. Eastern 9:00 central